foreign
[Music]
workloads to connect to external
Services outside of Google Cloud you
want to do it securely and without
having to manage or maintain your own
proxy
Cloud swp secure web proxy provides a
simple cloud-first web proxy for cloud
workload protection
it provides scalable security for your
cloud workloads and enables content
inspection with granular policy control
of web traffic from Google Cloud hosted
workloads to internet destinations and
between Google Cloud hosted workloads
the cloud first secure web proxy from
Google gives you flexibility and control
with full visibility that helps you
prevent outbound connections to known
bad URLs and domains with Cloud swp you
have the flexibility to design policies
aligned to your Cloud environment which
simplifies your setup and management of
web egress security for your cloud
workloads
for example
cloudswp allows you to set up policies
that are Cloud identity focused and
specific to web content
cloudswp's policy construction uses
objects with a cloud context like secure
tags or service accounts
moreover
cloudswp also supports TLS inspection
that lets you inspect the encrypted web
traffic and enforce security policies
down to the full URL and destination
path
Cloud swp also comes with a built-in
integration with cloudnat that lets you
customize Network address translation
from resources in your Cloud environment
making outbound connections
is useful in cases when you need a
workload to connect to a SAS service
which requires a loud list to specific
IPS for access
simple in some cases doesn't always mean
expandable but cloudswp provides
scalable security for your cloud
workloads with protection that auto
scales with your network architecture
and usage needs
it is managed for you so as your
business grows and your workloads make
connections to internet destinations
you don't need to worry about scaling up
your proxy infrastructure as your
traffic grows that is already taken care
of
this isn't to say that it can't be
configured or doesn't provide
customization options cloud swp is
integrated at the platform level with
broader Google Cloud products and
services for example you can configure
logging in Cloud logging and automate
your infrastructure using infrastructure
as code tools like terraform
all of this comes with elastic scaling
and line rate TLS inspection
Cloud swp offers an easy to use and
robust proxy with TLS inspection to
provide tighter web egress protection of
your cloud workloads
even though it works out of the box you
can get into the nitty-gritty details
with granular controls for advanced use
cases
granular TLS inspection allows you to
block or allow urls this feature enables
granular control over web requests
including URL paths and headers
you can also set policies based on the
source of the traffic using identifiers
like secure tags service counts and IPS
getting this granular is foundational to
complete Security and threat prevention
but if you don't need this level of
granularity you can also allow or block
traffic simply based on the fully
qualified domain name or fqdn of the
destination
Cloud swp works out of the box for the
majority of use cases with no VMS to set
up no software updates to make manually
and scales with your workloads and
traffic
saving time in both setup and day-to-day
operations
to find out more about how you can use a
cloud first secure web proxy that is
simple scalable and robust without
having to maintain or update it
check out the documentation on Google
Cloud swp using the link on the screen
and in the description below
[Music]